si vous avez vu strangers in vous avez
sans doute déjà entendu parler de
l'isolation sensorielle si vous l'avez
pas vu restait quand même parce que ça
va vous intéresser
et en plus je vais pas vous spoiler
produits
l'isolation sensorielle c'est le genre
de sujet qu'il vaut mieux avoir testé
pour pouvoir en parler et qu'on comprend
mieux quand on voit vraiment de quoi il
s'agit alors on va y aller et on
discutera sur place mais avant km
transformation sérieux transformation
ouais alors par contre une désolation
sont sans réelle c'est sans maillot
demain le principe de l'isolation
sensorielle c'est de lait tous ses sens
au repos pour que le cerveau est un
minimum de stimulation et puisse
atteindre un état de conscience
intermédiaire pour supprimer un maximum
de sollicitations extérieures on se
place dans un caisson dans lequel le
noir et le silence sont complets et qui
remplit d'une ossature et en celle de
magnésium dans laquelle le corps flotte
très haut à la surface sans avoir aucun
effort à fournir l'eau et maintenir une
température idéale pour éviter les
sensation de chaud et de froid
et pour éviter les frottements des
tissus on enlève le maillot même être
lavé grand salle avant d'aller flotter
on se lave comme à la piscine avec un
savon au ph neutre
petite astuce confort destruction rapide
avancée
bombay avant de se mettre dans le bain
un peu l'histoire
[Musique]
l'intérêt pour l'isolation sensorielle
elles datent des années 50 le premier
caisson été mis au point dans le cadre
de travaux sur la conscience par john
lilly un neuroscientifique à la fois
très sérieux et complètement chansons il
a par exemple essayer d'apprendre à
parler à des dauphins et il a mené un
certain nombre de ces expériences sous
lsd ou souquet tallinn d'ailleurs les
deux sont peut-être un peu lié au début
le modèle de caisson d'isolation
sensorielle était moyennement
confortable mais ça s'est amélioré au
fil du temps pour arriver au modèle
qu'on connaît aujourd'hui le principe à
continuer à être utilisés à travers les
décennies suivantes tour à tour comme
moyen d'atteindre une sorte de nirvana
hippie puis par des médecins pour
traiter des troubles anxieux par des
artistes pour développer leur créativité
par des sportifs pour préparer des
compétitions ou récupérer après
aujourd'hui il ya des centres de
flottaison un peu partout dans le monde
si vous vous renseigner sur le sujet
vous lirez sûrement que l'isolation
sensorielle permet à votre cerveau de
produire des ondes d'état c'est à dire
de se caler sur le rythme
caractéristiques de la phase
intermédiaire entre une phase d'éveil et
une phase de sommeil alors j'en ai parlé
avec un médecin chercheur spécialiste
des neurosciences et ils ont qu'a priori
il n'y a pas de vraie recherche
scientifique sur le sujet etc
l'électrophysiologie cérébrale c'est un
peu plus compliqué que ça les premières
minutes sont un peu difficile parce
qu'il faut se faire à l'idée qu'on va
flotter comme ça dans le noir à respirer
de la vapeur pendant une heure mais
petit à petit je me suis laissé aller
j'ai trouvé ma position et c'était
vraiment paisible c'est un peu qu'elle
est traumatisante
mais avec les organes génitaux qui
baigne dans le sel bon à un moment je me
suis grattée les sourcils
ce n'était pas une bonne idée je saurais
pas trop dire si j'ai dormi ou pas
apparemment c'est habituel est en tout
cas j'ai eu des espèces des
hallucinations visuelles n'en aurait
rien d'aussi méchant que ça mais plutôt
vous savez comme ces espèces de forme un
peu lumineuse là qu'apparaissent quand
on regarde dans le noir on va là pareil
sauf que c'était beaucoup plus nette
mais non mais pas du tout mais qu'est ce
que c'est que ça roma
en gros j'ai vu des yeux flotter dans le
noir et les pièces d'une maison en
enfilade comme si je me déplaçais dans
un jeu vidéo en vue subjective
allez savoir pourquoi non cherchez pas
c'est juste qu'à un moment il a aussi
semblé entendre comme si un groupe de
rock répétait dans la pièce d'à côté
bon en fait je me suis renseigné il n'y
avait pas de coupe d'europe dans la
pièce d'à côté
bon en tout cas j'ai vécu une expérience
très particulière et je suis sortie
extrêmement relaxer voilà ma séance
vient de se terminer
je suis totalement détendu j'ai perdu
complètement la notion du temps et la
notion de l'espace pendant l'heure que
ça va durer allez rentrer à la maison
maintenant
bon alors qu'est ce qu'on retient de
tout ça scientifiquement parlant il n'y
a pas grand chose qui tient la route à
part une étude suédoise qui a montré que
c'était efficace sur le stress sur
l'anxiété et même sur la dépression
c'est déjà pas mal
moi ce que je me suis dit c'est que si
les premières minutes dans le caisson
sont aussi difficiles c'est parce qu'on
est plus habitué à lâcher prise et dans
l'histoire c'est peut-être ça le plus
précieux dont camarades
neuroscientifique et moi on est tombé
d'accord sur un point
l'isolation sensorielle c'est un super
moyen de relaxation parce que ça permet
de se relâcher à la fois physiquement et
psychologiquement
sans rien avoir à faire et en étant tout
seul avec soi-même c'est rare est-ce
qu'on fait une expérience vraiment
étonnante c'est que contrairement à ce
qu'on pourrait croire - on est stimulé
physiquement plus notre corps se repose
et plus notre cerveau est actif chez
certains ça stimule la créativité chez
d'autres ça favorise introspection chez
d'autres encore
ça fait apparaître des yeux qui flotte
dans les airs chacun réagit différemment
et chacun en retire quelque chose de
personnel
d'ailleurs si vous avez testé ou si vous
avez envie de le faire après cette vidéo
revenu me raconter ça dans les
commentaires
ça fera plaisir en attendant dtc c'est
fini pour aujourd'hui on se retrouve la
semaine prochaine pour une nouvelle
vidéo
d'ici là mettez vous bien et surtout
portez vous
[Applaudissements]